- Rent a brain.
We may be tokens, but we're
damn good-looking ones.
You think it would
dishonor Dr. King's memory
if I went to sit in the back of the bus?
- So we need to talk about
how iconic Jodie Landon is.
(upbeat music)
20 years ago, Daria came to MTV.
The show focused on
the shade icon herself,
Daria Morgendorffer and
her family and schoolmates
and Lawndale High.
- This looks well-balanced.
- Ew.
- Dammit,
we've got four mouths to feed!
Food costs money.
- I knew it.
- The show was really ahead of its time
It touched on feminism, social
class, and thanks to one
of the show's few characters
of color, Jodie, race as well.
Homegirl literally ran
Lawndale High School.
- Thank you, Jodie Landon,
Valedictorian of her graduating
class of Lawndale High.
- I'm president of the French club,
Vice President of Student
Council, editor of yearbook,
and I'm also on the tennis team.
- She had the black
boyfriend, box braids popping,
unapologetic attitude, she
carried herself with so much
class and dignity.
- Someday I'd like to own my own business,
maybe a consulting firm geared
toward minority startups.
- She truly was someone that I wanted
to be best friends with.
But she was also very
vocal about what it mean
to be under this gaze of
being the perfect minority
and the token black girl.
- At home, I'm Jodie, I can
say or do whatever feels right,
but at school, I'm the
Queen of the Negroes,
the perfect African-American
teen, the role model
for all of the other
African-American teens at Lawndale,
oops, where'd they do?
- To its credit, the show
positioned Jodie to be the biggest
critic of the show's
overwhelming whiteness.
- Isn't it great how they keep electing us
Homecoming King and Queen every year?
- Yes, it's such a generous
and enlightened gesture,
it completely makes up
for the town's utter lack
of diversity in my mind.
- And we're playing into it.
- Damn college application.
- This is so humiliating.
- Jodie was woke before woke
even knew what woke was.
- Why play into this stupid charade
any more than we have to?
- What happened?
- Oh what the hell,
we may be tokens but we're
damn good-looking ones.
- Not only were Jodie and
her boyfriend Mack Mackenzie
some of the few characters of color,
but they were also the
only secondary characters
to have a three-dimensional storyline
independent from the show's white lead.
In the show's film-length
finale Is It College Yet?
Jodie and her parents
debate over which college
Jodie was going to go to.
Would it be the elitest Ivy
League school Questmoore
or the historically black college Turner.
- I wanna go to Turner, at
least for a year or two.
- You wanna go to college to relax?
- Relax socially, stop being the black kid
and just be a kid, I'm tired
of being in the extreme
minority and I don't wanna
go to a place where people
might think I got in just
because I'm African-American.
- Now in the end, Jodie
chooses to go to Turner
with her parents' support.
- My parents said if I was
so upset about Questmoore
that I'd apply to Turner
behind their backs,
they had to respect my feelings,
they told me I'd earned
the right to be treated like an adult.
- As we look back on the
20-year anniversary of Daria,
it's time that we give Jodie Landon
the respect and credit that she deserves.
Her poise and dignity to
personify what it means
to be black girl magic.